[Music]
thanks for joining our session I'm Adam
Michaelson I'm a product manager here at
Google on the IOT team joining me
shortly will be a couple of folks from
our partner cog night gear n'gou and
sundry ham Erland so they'll be coming
up in a minute and describing in detail
their expertise around IOT and
industrial but before we dive in on that
I wanted to just do a quick informal
survey so for the folks in the room
around IOT Internet of Things how many
folks in the room have deployed an IOT
implementation just by show of hands or
are planning to do so say the next 12
months wow that's that's a lot of people
so that's exciting to hear what we've
seen from analysts is there's basically
a claim that somewhere between 8 billion
and 14 billion IOT devices exist out
there today and that's a lot of devices
it's also a big range 8 to 14 billion I
think one of the reasons might be when
you think about IOT a lot of the
implementations we see use a gateway
right look at think of this room and if
you want to control all the lights via
IOT then a lot of the implementations we
see is will be a central box somewhere
some Linux machine that all these lights
are talking to on-premises and then that
gateway will connect to a cloud so what
is it that is the counting as the 8
billion is it the one gateway or is it
each individual light I don't know I
feel sorry for the poor analyst who's
going around counting those 8 billion
devices but it's a lot of devices more
and more all the time and all of those
devices are generating incredible
amounts of data and dealing with the
intake of all that data is one of the
challenges when it comes to IOT even
though there are so many devices that
are online there's another statistic
which isn't so great and I don't know
what the experience of the audience is
that we've seen
that people claim that around 1% of the
data that's actually collected for IOT
is actually used to generate some sort
of a positive outcome business outcome
and so what's happening to that other
99% of the data that is not generating
that outcome there's an opportunity
there for everyone to say how are we
going to collect this data and make sure
that where the data were collecting has
maximal value so that's one of the
purposes where we could say see googles
mission come in so googles mission is to
organize the world's information and
make it universally useful so when it
comes to say Google search that's easy
to think about pulling information from
lots of web sites organizing it so that
it makes sense providing a nice handy
search bar that you could type into and
then at the end giving you useful
results so you tie that chain together
IOT has the same opportunity where we're
collecting all this data it needs to be
organized in a uniform way and then made
useful so we think about the lights in
the room are collecting ones type of IOT
data or telemetric data the HVAC system
might be another one the alarm system is
another one how is all this data being
collected organized to make sense and
then produce a useful outcome that has
business value so some of that some of
the topics we want to talk about today
but before diving right into the
industrial use cases I just want to
spend a couple of minutes in baseline us
on what are Google's IOT offerings so we
know what the terms are and all of a
common understanding before we dive deep
into the industrial use cases so this is
an image of Google's IOT platform for
those who haven't seen it it's called
IOT core IOT core is a component that
exists within Google Cloud Google cloud
services IOT core has a few major
components built into it one component
is this protocol bridge that is what
will enable us to take these edge
devices and safely and securely send
that data into the cloud we often will
talk
HTTP or a more popular protocol for IOT
is MQTT which is very efficient for IOT
use cases the other component of IOT
core is this device manager which allows
us to understand each and every device
both in like example we were talking
with before with a gateway like in this
room if we had gate with lights we would
under we will run or understand the
Gateway that's talking to us but also
each device that's connected to that
gateway would want to be known to the
device manager so as data is being sent
from these devices into the cloud we can
say oh that's a light and that's an HVAC
end and that's an alarm or whatever it
may be another component of IOT core are
some edge modules where we have
libraries that you can take embed into
your edge devices that have pre-built
connections to IOT core you don't have
to use those edge components you can use
the raw API of the IOT core cloud
modules but those components are there
and extensible for you just for a quick
start so you can get your IOT journey
going a little faster now behind IOT
core is the rest of Google cloud the
first module we connect to is pub/sub
it's a large message bus that's used
across many Google components to allow
services to interoperate once the data
gets the pub/sub then it can be sent to
other Google services commonly we see
services such as data flow that can
transform data so for example if you
have a data coming in from a light and a
late data coming in from an HVAC and
they're in different formats we have to
make them look common cloud data flow
will help us do that we can also call
cloud functions if we want to run
business logic on real-time data that's
coming in in a streaming way and then
many services behind that to store the
data we have multiple storage options
that you can choose based on what type
of data it is how frequently it's coming
in how frequently you want to do
analytics on that data and then there
are analysis tools that we have such as
data studio as well as a suite of
machine learning tools so this is a this
is
all the Google components clearly but
it's ones that we typically see on an
IOT implementation
you heard potentially yesterday in the
keynote about multi cloud and hybrid
cloud and a lot of the implementations
we see aren't quite as clean as every
single component up here is one of these
Google components which we'd love to see
but we have many partners in there are
many players in IOT so oftentimes this
architectures a suite of tools that we
see between Google components partner
components to come together for an
architecture so one way to sort of think
about the various components that are
involved in an IOT architecture is this
simple three buckets on the Left we see
ingestion to gather the data so IOT core
is there to get the data sometimes you
have data that doesn't need an IOT
broker it's already ready to be ingested
so for that you can use something like
pub/sub just to take the data ingest it
in the middle we need to clean up that
data process it in its the organized
step in the Google mission here we see
data flow functions data storage various
components on the far right is where we
have to do analysis and understand this
data and if we don't see Google
components on all of these that's fine
what's more important is for the folks
in the room implementing this they have
a way of laying out the components
you're gonna have any Ryo T and know
what functions they're going to operate
on so before when we were seeing 99% of
the data in IOT is not reaching its full
potential a lot of the reason why is
because the process and clean step isn't
cleaning up the data as much as we need
so that data is looking like it's in
data silo from the lights in the HVAC
and etc and the other reason is because
there's so much of this data it's not
hard for a single device to generate
gigabytes of data in a single year if
that device is talking multiple times
per minute or multiple times per second
and then multiply that times all the
devices and we're talking about an
enormous data load to be able to
understand that data so we just don't
have the human capital to go through all
that data and that's where tools like
machine like like
let me go back when the machine learning
tools come in that will help us
understand over here on the right to
review all that data so that let the
Machine look at the data and figure out
how to find the insights rather than the
people and that's why ml and IOT go
together so well so on the next slide I
wanted to talk about machine learning
where machine learning also has lots of
tools you could use so what's a
framework that we can think about in
terms of which ml components we want to
use and this is another block of three
so here on the Left we have Google
components that are pre-built ready to
use our data our model meaning for
example vision you we have a Google
vision machine learning component that
you can upload an image pizza here's a
pizza and Google will say I think that's
a pizza and then you can go ahead and
use that data or whatever it's a
building or it's a dog that sort of
thing in these components on the Left
there are more and more of them all the
time
very simple to use a great place to
start your ml journey with all this data
but oftentimes you'll say ok I know
that's a pizza but I run a pizza company
and I want it to know that it's one of
my pizzas because I have all these
different pizzas that I make so how can
i train that model and that's where the
middle components the retrain models
Auto ml will come in so like Auto ml
vision is a tool you can use and the
models are pre-built
but the training is not in here you'll
upload an image and say here's pizza and
it's my supreme pizza and here's another
one and it's my whatever deep-dish and
these are the others so that Google will
learn those images so when it sees
images of those in the future maybe as
the pizzas are coming out of the oven
and you want to make sure it's matching
what the customer ordered something
could take a picture of it match the
point of sale and say yep that's the
supreme pizza just like the customer
ordered with extra mushrooms and that's
where tools like Ottawa ml can come in
any of that training you do is your data
none of it would filter into the left
none of it filters into Google it's all
your data and then sometimes customers
need even more they need not only custom
trained models but they need to build
their own models and that's where
there's you'll the data scientists
define the rules you need define the
data sets you can create great tools
like tensorflow
either the open source or the hosted
version on Google and have models that
are custom to your business and
customers will often start on the left
use the out-of-the-box ones and work
their way to the right as they need to
because the more you go to the right the
more coding you have to do and the more
the more coding you have to do it unless
you're worrying about your core business
and so that's why we offer this suite of
tools so with that we have a baseline of
IOT core in the components so now what I
want to do is invite gear up and he's
gonna describe to you how cognate has
taken these tools assembled them use in
an industrial IOT use case and brought
them into the real world and they'll
share with us some of the lessons
they've learned in some of the tips for
all of us to take advantage of here
thank you thank you hello everyone my
name is gear I'm CTO and co-founder of
cog night which is a software company
the works with a set Heavy Industries
what that means is it's basically
industry that has big machines that cost
lots of money so we work mainly with oil
and gas also in power and utilities and
shipping now this talk will focus on
shipping because it is the most
challenging edge environment that we've
encountered but before we dive into that
I I want to make sure that you are all
awake so quick show of hands how many of
you have had a cup of coffee this
morning yes that's what I thought as we
all know coffee is one of the primary or
most important inputs to writing a good
software called but what are what are
the inputs to coffee it turns out that
coffee sits at the top of a very long
complex industrial value chain and you
don't have to backtrack very far to
understand this because the beans before
they came to most
only they were on a truck and that truck
needed fuel hence the oil and gas
industry or in where I'm from in Norway
I believe 60% of new vehicles sold last
month for electric so there you have
power and utilities - and the truck
needed to be manufactured from steel so
you are mining steel mills and before
the beans got onto the truck they were
probably on a ship so it's but there's
this huge value chain which touches all
the industries that we are in and it's
not just coffee it's everything that we
surround ourselves with that kind of
make our lives comfortable and
convenient and that's why I think it's
such a privilege to use data and
algorithms to drive industry to be more
efficient produce more for less energy
input make it safer yeah it's it's
really quite quite the potential there
so when we started called night we set
out and we had this kind of naive belief
that we would use sensor data and we do
ml on that and things would be great now
it turns out industry is a little bit
different from consumer in that there
are so many different data silos
different protocols you know different
systems that you have to integrate with
and in order to understand the sensor
data it's you need a lot of context
around it so maybe you need the
engineering data maybe you need a CAD
model to figure out where the sensor
actually is located or you need the
topology of how how stuff flows through
a power plant and so we were very lucky
to start out with a large industrial
customer very early to be exposed to
this reality of industry I think the
core problem is that the life cycle of
industrial equipment is so much longer
than the life cycle of software you know
a plant that's five years old is new
software that's five years old is old
so then with this data complexity that
we witness our mission quickly became to
liberate all this data from the
industrial silos move it to somewhere
where it's always available and clean it
so that it becomes understandable so
that it's easy to build value from it as
you can see it's quite a complex reality
out there as Adam was saying the the
scale of data is enormous a single
sensor is sending one value per second
will produce one gigabyte of data every
two years and that doesn't sound like a
lot but typical ship has 5000 of these
an oil platform can have a hundred
thousand so it becomes a lot of data and
that actually informed our choice of
Google Cloud as the vendor because we
believe in the ability of Google to run
distributed systems at a scale that's
one step ahead of everyone else so we
want to reuse the same infrastructure
that's powering YouTube Google search
and Gmail to store all this data for
instance we're storing all the IOT data
all the sensor data time series in
system called BigTable which is a
ridiculously distributed key-value store
and how we structure data into big
BigTable to be able to query it
efficiently and you know store data
efficiently could fill an entire talk
and in fact it does I did a talk on that
last year up next so if you're
interested in the details of that you
can google code night next BigTable and
you'll find out talk as someone who
loves technology it's really easy to get
kind of sidetracked into building
technology for technology's sake and
that usually doesn't lead to great
outcomes in the end and I've been guilty
of that in my past
so it makes sense to sit down with the
people in industry figure out what the
real valuable use cases are and some of
these use cases will span we see in
every vertical every industry that we
are in such a fuel efficiency or energy
and fishin see in more in general nobody
wants to waste energy energy is a cost
in fact in shipping it is the number-one
cost a single product percent reduction
in fuel costs for a you know an average
fried chip is a 50k per ship annual
savings and for a fleet of 100 ships
that's 5 million and by the way we're
not targeting 1% so our customers
estimate anywhere from 5 to 15% savings
depending on the type of ship and the
age of the ship and then there are other
use cases which are specific to each
industry such a weather impact on cargo
you want to be able to tell your
customer that you didn't damage the
goods and you can measure the motion of
the ship at any time so you can even say
hey look I didn't go through two rough
seas this is what a data silo looks like
we have this great piece of equipment a
sensor that is using lasers to measure
the torque on the propeller axle on a
ship so it's like the laser underwater
sending a beam along the axle it's
reflected it's detected it measures the
microscopic deformation of the axle due
to the force and acted on it now
contrast that with the way that this
data is sent to the cloud because what
happens is every day this guy walks down
to the engine control room and writes
down the value on a piece of paper and
it goes into a report
but that's not like the reason this
particular measure is important is if
you want to solve the energy efficiency
use case for a ship you need to be able
to break down the fuel used to ship
motion into its two main parts that's
the engine efficiency so how much force
do you get onto the water via the
propeller for each unit of fuel used and
the whole performance so for the force
that the propeller acts on the the water
how far do you go and a once per day
resolution is nowhere near what you need
to solve the use case because the engine
settings change too often weather
changes all the time so here to get the
data out we have to install an adapter
and this is a pretty common pattern so
the data sets in a separate network you
can't talk to it on the ship's network
which converts the data and sends it
onto the ship Ethernet where it can be
picked up by an edge box and you have
many of these systems that you need to
liberate data from here's another issue
connectivity the good news is that you
can be connected virtually anywhere on
the planet the bad news it's it's kind
of expensive and the bandwidth is not
great one of the things that surprised
me about this is that you actually get
quite decent latency your data can go
from the laser to the cloud in 200
milliseconds I find that pretty pretty
awesome but we have too much data to
send over this connection and most of
the data is not that useful for this use
case anyway
so given those constraints here's how we
approached solving the situation first
given the bandwidth constraints there is
a need for an edge component it needs to
manage the bandwidth so some of the data
is high-priority and should be sent
directly to the cloud some of the data
needs to be buffered on the edge stored
there until connectivity is better when
the ship is close to shore it will get
cellular coverage which is much cheaper
and much wider when you can bulk upload
that data you also may want to do some
processing on the data down sampling or
compressing the data in other ways for
instance vibration sensors on rotating
equipment will often send you data at 50
kilohertz so that's 50,000 data points
per second that's like 10 times more
than the rest of the sensors on the ship
you can send all that data and you don't
need to because if you do a Fourier
transform convert the signal into the
frequency space and send the
coefficients of each frequency that
constit constitutes the signal then you
get almost exactly the same curve with
one thousandth of the data transmitted
which is also a very cool stat and you
may also want to use it as a cache if
you have applications on the ship if you
have like a digital worker application
running on android phones where the
workers on the ship can get all the
sensor data from the ship at any time
they may not want to go via the cloud
for that so you can ask the hedge box
directly and there are also more
interesting use cases which we'll get
into which does more interesting compute
and predictions on the edge also this is
not your typical
IOT consumer scenario where you have to
have very very light Hardware it
actually makes sense to invest in a
rugged Hardware that won't break
in this case and it also needs a bit of
storage because it needs to buffer all
this data it pretty like an average ship
will produce something like 500
megabytes per day of data and it can be
at sea for up to 2 months at a time so
you need some storage there and you also
don't want to lose that data if one disk
dies so it's a raid configuration has a
rugged PC with no moving parts so here's
what the architecture looks like you
have all these silos at the bottom the
green boxes they're typically on their
own networks you can't access them via
the ship Network so you need a physical
adapter and in our case those are always
set up to be read-only which makes the
whole situation less scary from a
security point of view then it's picked
up by the edge box what it needs to do
is translate from all these different
industrial protocols the Modbus the OPC
OPC UA MQTT and a wide variety of other
dialects that you need to talk
once you've translated the data into
into the cab same format put it on
another cue and then it's processed it's
matched against a list of high-priority
tags and some is sent directly over the
satellite link which is managed by cloud
IOT core and the other data is stored
and sent over a cellphone connection one
of the things that we didn't do what we
are considering doing is to move to EDX
EDX is a framework for fore-edge
solutions which will do some of the
translation for you and it has a lot of
components that you can put together to
solve for from any of these scenarios
one of the things so cognate is almost
200 people and it's just over 2 years
old one of the things that we value very
highly is speed and one of the things
that we
to get speed is to always try to use
managed solutions where we can you don't
want to reinvent the wheel and when
you're looking at this next slide you
might wonder if we do anything at all
because it looks like Google is doing
all the work but there is some stuff
there like cloud functions we actually
write the stuff that's in the cloud
function and kubernetes engine where we
have our business logic so on the cloud
side basically what i io T core gives us
is a managed connection we don't need to
scale that thing and it has encryption
authentication is taken care of and it
conveniently puts the data on the pop
sub-q which we use for the rest of our
system so it's to us it's we just
interact with the pub sub q which
triggers cloud function which translates
the data on the Q into API calls to our
API gateway so our our solution is used
by many customers in many verticals many
industries which have slightly different
ways of sending data so not all of it is
going through IOT core and that's why
the API kind of access to the one gate
which is the common denominator there
that's why you need the translation same
thing with the daily logs the the
backfilled data it's uploaded GCP no
Google Cloud Storage I mean and that
triggers a cloud function whenever a new
file is uploaded which does the same
translation so it's the same protocol
buffer based format now when we get to
the yellow box we have a pipeline for
processing the data
structuring it so that it doesn't use a
lot of space and computing roll ups so
that you can get you know do advanced
queries with millisecond the latency and
this pipeline we've run that ten million
data points per second so every
component there the kubernetes engine
autoscaler pops up skeltox incredibly
well and BigTable so it all scales
horizontally it's very fast and then
when we do run predictions on this data
we use ml engine to host those models
and we use cloud scheduler to do
periodic predictions no no so we don't
write back to the control systems so the
use cases that we have are about
advicing say the captain you know you
need to slow down a bit because you're
using too much fuel or you need to clean
the hull because there's marine growth
which is slowing you down it's not it's
something that you can do parallel
periodically maybe you do a prediction
every minute but we do there you can
think of cases where you'd want to kind
of do streaming analytics when it comes
in but right now it's not necessary
security so the edge environment is kind
of scary the control systems that you
deal with there are set up they usually
don't have the concept of authentication
so if you can talk to them you can do
whatever you want with them a couple of
principles that we implied we don't want
to invent our own encryption scheme
without Google IOT core handle that we
have no inbound routes to the edge and
there's a physically separated network
so we only read to these sensors so that
makes it a lot less scary to be on the
edge but security is definitely a big
concern here so bring that together here
we have one of the dashboards which will
show you and verify that
was not damaged this is the ship's
motion in all the different directions
axles 10 Hertz with 200 milliseconds
latency so if you're shipping cars for
instance you could share this with a car
manufacturer and really you know assert
that you didn't damage any other goods
it's also very important input to the
energy efficiency use case because if
you have rough seas your engine will
have to work more in fact very rough
seas can make the engine shut down
entirely which is what happened with the
cruise ship Vikings guy a couple of
weeks ago outside the coast of Norway
rough seas and the engines tripped as a
result of that leaving the ship in a
very precarious situation and then when
we move on to the more advanced use
cases that involve machine learning you
have an of course anomaly detection
which is very much used in predictive
analytics the the models they're usually
based on clustering or forecasting so
you're looking for data that's that you
haven't seen before
basically and then you're alerting
someone inspection we have a lot of
sensors that are not just you know
pressure temperature flow we have a
sensor in in our pocket which is a
camera and you can use that to extract
loads of interesting information using
image recognition so inspection and we
with trained for instance last year we
trained an auto ml model which detected
damaged wires and you can imagine having
drones to fly around and detect these
these faulty things or corrosion which
is already being done by some companies
and in those cases you definitely do not
want to send all the footage to the
cloud if you're on a satellite
connection yes so guide I heard some
rumors about your demo last year that
you did some had a windmill on stage and
did some machine learning as well that
must have been pretty terrifying yes a
good demo is exciting to the audience
and very scary to the presenter so I
think you know especially when you are
moving parts and you're doing machine
learning which is never really 100
percent that's that's always scary but
you know the one trick is you can always
blame the Wi-Fi but yeah so I think we
should which would try to top that and
do something even scarier this year yeah
definitely
and that's why we brought this tiny
model of a chemical plant it continues
the streams live sensor data to cognise
data fusion via Google IOT core so
typically you use this sensor data to
visualize visualize it in charts like
you can see soon on this screen so here
you can see the temperature it's about
27 degrees that's pretty hot but there
are other ways to visualize your data as
well in cognate we see the power of
using 3d models as a tool to visualize
your data and that is definitely I use a
tool for the future I see that but what
what if you don't have a 3d model that's
definitely a big issue and a challenge
for the industry because either you
don't have a 3d model or perhaps the 3d
model already
got got all from the day of assembly and
was has become kind of useless so that's
why we have developed an application
that helps you generate this up-to-date
3d models in order to visualize your
data in a better way you're not
connected I think okay the way it's the
Wi-Fi yeah definitely the Wi-Fi so what
we can see here is the model on screen I
take a single picture and I detect
features on it I could take one more and
then it guides me through the entire
process so this is something that I do
now on my phone but this is something
that you can do with any kind of camera
and it's not something that you have to
do yourself either okay so you just need
the photos for this to work you don't
need a special camera you might wonder
why there's a helipad here that's
because sometimes when we run this we
use a drone unfortunately if you look
closely on the sign outside the door
here it says no drones are allowed and
yeah that complexity of getting that
permission in time was unfortunately too
high for us but it doesn't matter you
can use anything like your mobile phone
or drone or you know GoPro on someone's
helmet it doesn't really matter
yeah so what's happening to those
pictures right now yeah now that I'm
finished taking pictures I just upload
them to cognise data fusion where the
magic happens and right now it's
processing all the pictures and should
we take a look at the final result all
right let's try that nah Wi-Fi has
failed and here it looks like we've got
a nice model to it so
suddenly we have a 3d model that's up to
date with the exact same dimension the
exact same proportion and also you get a
good overview of the texture on the
model as well but if you want to view
the time series in their right context
here I guess you have to do some kind of
manual yeah yeah so the thing is that
this is definitely a really good tool
for the for the future of the industry
and but the thing is that wouldn't it be
cool if we could link this model with
the data that we have inside the cognate
data fusion platform and that's actually
something that we can do so if we take a
close look on the tags that are located
all around this model you can see tio2
tier one those kinds of tags is
something that is present on all
platforms or in ships as well and
identify the different assets that
identifier is something that we also
have in cognize data fusion so what we
can do is to use the same pictures that
we took here and try to detect all the
different tags using Google vision and
when we have detected them we store the
location of all the different assets and
also which asset it is shall we see if
it got them in there and the end result
is here
so what was happening behind the scene
there is we used a model called Yolo you
only look once which is an object
detection model and that thing is
trained to look for this this mission
here right target's tear the tags but it
it can identify other stuff too like
rust or faulty wires etc and place it
right there in in the 3d model yeah
that's instant situational awareness
there Andy this room is too hot it's so
we can demonstrate this for you let's
see if I'm hotter or cooler than twenty
eight point two degrees so I'm cooler
yeah I'm almost dead I guess maybe it
maybe you have some cold feet yeah but
then we're the inside operational limit
again and that's good because it turns
red when it's above 27 yeah you're
actually cooling the room down yeah but
all right so yeah and this is the model
that you can update 24/7 at least when
you have a robot to take the pictures
for you and that's really convenient
when it comes to detect when corrosion
when corrosion started you can actually
travel back in time you can check
whether the corrosion mark was there
only two weeks ago or perhaps two years
ago so to complete five minutes ago we
only had a chemical plant that streamed
live sensor data but now we also have an
up-to-date 3d model that displays our
sensor values in a really intuitive way
thank you
[Applause]
you can you can do this with real
industrial equipment - all right this is
data now streaming in from the North Sea
and it identified the plates on that
equipment - and also here you can find
some things that shouldn't be here for
instance these ladders they're not
supposed to be in this zone so it's a
health safety environment issue right
there then let's wrap up here's my
checklist I wish this checklist was
shorter but it's not I mean this is the
reality of why it's hard to create value
in industry so you have to start with
the valuable use cases start with that
and talk to the people in the business
because you will depend on them to
implement it later so it better be
something that they think is valuable -
then you need to figure out if you have
the data that's necessary to solve those
use cases usually you have the sensors
but you may have to do some work to
liberate the data and then you need to
clean the data make it so that you can
actually solve your use cases for
instance linking it to a 3d model it may
seem trivial when you have kind of a
plant with four sensors but if you have
a hundred thousand sensors and you send
the data scientist in to find the right
sensors to do predictive maintenance on
your one compressor or whatever it's
going to take months if you don't have
good tools to figure out what sensor is
is where and which and relevant to the
use case then you need to do stuff with
the data so if that's algorithms usually
you don't build your own you merely
apply you know other people's work most
companies don't do machine learning
research they do application of known
research to new problems
now once you're you're satisfied with
those results you need to monitor the
quality of the data because your model
probably won't handle you know garbage
data coming in and these systems these
sensors will give you a lot of crap data
from time to time there will be
connectivity issues there will be you
know flipping bits here and there it's
it's it's a quite challenging thing to
do so you have to build that trust in
the data and then you have to change the
way that people work in the company
there it's very useful if you kind of
introduce your use case early on so they
know this is not something you made up
in worst case you just you've done a lot
of work and you get to this stage and
it's like way this isn't useful that
sucks so and then last that's when
you've done all those things you profit
and that's what LT is really about
otherwise it's not sustainable here are
some pointers to get you started so for
IOT core all the AI solutions that
Google has to offer we have a booth down
in the lower level and there are
industry solutions so it's on the left
after taking the escalator down contact
us there if you have questions thank you
and also don't forget to rate this talk
we definitely appreciate your feedback
so that you know next year we can have
an even better talk and even scare your
demo thank you
[Music]